what is the difference between a woman
playing hard to get and not being
interested
well i won't play hard to get would just
literally walk away or something like
that and then a woman not interested
would you say go [ __ ] yourself and go on
do you ever think women give mixed
signals to men
i don't know
i don't know you don't know
have you ever flirted with a guy for the
attention
is who is wife material
that's clever okay
who's wife material the best cook but
the worst head or the best head but the
worst cook best head head gives birth
head
what what
yeah
so so the girl is either the best head
but the worst cook she can't cook or
the
or vice versa
we can always order in can't we what we
can always order in so yeah yeah head
first hit first then two seconds could
you argue the way to a man's heart is
good
[Music]
i know is it i'll get your heart out
he loves it no he's not my boyfriend
who's wife material the best cook but
the worst head or the best head but the
worst cook i don't know
best cocoa what worst head as in like as
in you mean looking what is in like you
guys do not have that term there no no
so so best best coco
material the best cook but the worst
head or the best head but the worst cook
best coke
really yeah yeah best coke for me why
because you can always sort yourself out
can't you
best head and worst cook why
well
you can always order in who is wife
material
the the best cook and the worst head
or the best head and the worst cook
as in the best head do you guys that
have that term i'm american
oh blow job
because sex is very important
so you would put the sex above the
cooking
difficult because my wife's good at both
so
um
it'll be um
yeah difficult question you have to pick
one
tricky
okay with outsource outsource the food
outsource the food
none are problem solvers that's what a
lot of guys have said today do that okay
who's wife material
the the best cook with the worst head
or the best head and the worst cook um
i would say
the best cook worst head
the best cook worst had yeah yeah yeah
why
oh no actually sorry sorry the other way
around because you can just teach them
how to cook they can learn as well okay
well you could you can't teach that i
mean i suppose but you know like all
experience to be fair
so
yeah you know what's funny almost every
guy i've asked has said this stuff
they'll all say we could order in 100
teach them how to cook order in yeah